If you're at a party this summer and wanna grab someones attention, you could try charming
the crowd with an improvised pan flute, or
you could go for a more direct approach.
In this project, we're turning bottle caps and
drink cans, into sports-style party whistles,
that'll give you the power you need, to
summon the attention you deserve
We’re all familiar with the term “lifehacks”
but this summer, the guys at mike’s hard
lemonade asked me to help put a refreshing
twist on it with what they’re calling “mikehacks"
"Mikehack" basically a lifehack that makes any social
occasion, more awesome.
I tried hot gluing some glass bottles together,
and found that yes, they really can work as
a pan flute. It's a pretty awesome idea, but
can be pretty messy and take up a lot of space. So
let's try making another kind of party favor,
that's just as awesome, but a little easier
to manage. We'll need to start this project
with an empty aluminum drink can. Now if we
use something like a pair of scissors to make
some strategic cuts, we can harvest a lightweight
sheet of aluminum metal. Now before you throw
the scraps away, make sure you save a tab
or two, because we'll need those for measurements,
in just a minute.
Alright, let's cut a long narrow strip from
the sheet metal, making sure the edges are
as straight as possible, then cut a smaller,
stubbier piece as well. You can see the long
strip is the width of a single can tab, while
the smaller piece is as wide, and as tall,
as two pieces laid side by side.
We need to join these pieces together with
the smaller rectangle centered on top, about
a quarter inch down from the end. The two
sides wrap around the back holding it in place,
and now you can snip the top corners off,
if you feel like it, and finish up by folding
the tab over to lock everything together.
We've just formed the mouthpiece for our whistle.
Now let's grab the other end of the strip
and push it back through the mouth piece,
being careful not to bend it. You'll see what
we're going to do with this, in just a minute.
Alright, it's time to get busy with our bottle
caps. I tried using a pair of scissors to
snip the sides, and cut a little notch in
each cap, so when the two bottoms are lined
up, they form a round container with a symmetrical
hole at the top.
Let's bring back the piece we made earlier
and fit the barrel inside one of the caps,
then expand it so it completely fills the
inside. Now that we know it fits together
nicely, we can line the inside of the cap
with some hot-glue, then place the rounded
strip back in position.
When the glue has hardened, it should look
like this.
Now this is the point where we form the noise
maker. Carefully cut the strip so it lines
up with the top of the notch, then pull the
scrap part out of the mouthpiece.
There's only one thing left to do, and that's to add
hot-glue to the other cap, and press the two
pieces firmly together, making sure the notches
line up symmetrically. Now for one last embellishment,
I tried cutting one of the tabs in half, and
hot-gluing it to the back, so now we have
the option of adding a lanyard. That'll just
make it fully accessible, anytime we want it.
The whistle works by directing air through
the mouthpiece, and splitting it over the
sharp edge of the metal. Not only does it
look good, but it actually sounds good too.
If you try rolling your tongue when you blow,
it'll sound a lot like a referee's whistle,
and it's really, really loud.
Well now you know how to convert your cans and bottle caps, into colorful and customizable party whistles,
that'll summon you attention when you need
it, and make a great conversation piece when
you don't. Well that's it for now. If you
liked this project, perhaps you'll like some
of my others. Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com